[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i'm going to be taking you
through some miniatures
by giants of the game i'm not talking
physical height
i am talking reputation in chess
history um and my three players that i
really want to highlight tonight
and if we have time maybe we'll get to a
special fourth
are the three players that happen to be
missing from
a certain top 50 players list that chess
24 is working on
um for those of you unfamiliar they are
going through a video series
highlighting the 50 best chess players
in their opinion and they
have yet to announce the top three
however i have some guesses
as to who they may be so our first
miniature tonight is actually going to
come
from the same tournament that i covered
uh last week
and that is the 1963 64 u.s championship
now
i didn't get a chance to look at this
game during that lecture because there
were just so many excellent games to
look at
but i want to highlight it here of
course this is the us championship where
bobby fischer went undefeated 11-0
a perfect score and he had his fair
share of brilliancies throughout that
event
so in this round he was up against
robert steinmeier and he chose of course
one e4 uh as he always said best
buy test steinmeier chose the carol khan
we get d4 d5 and bobby
chooses the classical variation with
knight c3 these days of course e5
is the more popular move at the top
level and really at the amateur level
as well this is how players with the
white pieces have been trying to put a
little bit of pressure on black's
position
but knight c3 of course is a perfectly
fine way of playing
uh this leads to d takes e4 black
doesn't really
want to further defend this pawn with
something like e6 and if you go
something like knight f6 then of course
e5 is going to kick the knight away
um yeah of course why not e6 well the
point of the opening is to develop the
bishop and e6 locks that bishop in but
okay that's enough of that
d takes e4 knight takes e4 bishop f5
again the point of the opening
in the caro con is to get this bishop
outside the pawn chain
knight g3 bishop back to g6 and now of
course
those of you familiar with this position
will know it's just all
very much mainline theory here bobby
chose knight f3
first highlighting this e5 square right
off the bat
robert steinmeier just plays the move
knight f6
and then we get the main h4 move by
white in this variation
and this is sort of the crux of of
white's play in this classical keracon
variation black gets the bishop outside
the pawn chain
but he has to spend now a second tempo
on the bishop
and after h4 it actually demands a third
tempo from the bishop how so well white
of course is making a threat if black
tries to develop
then h5 is going to essentially trap
this bishop
bishop f5 takes takes is of course a
pretty terrible pawn structure
for black with this king stuck in the
center of the board
so of course here h6 is what was chosen
by robert steinmeier giving this bishop
a flight square
and now normally in this opening you
would actually see white go after this
bishop once again
since black hasn't guarded e5 this could
be done with
uh bringing this knight to e5 or even
playing h5
just to kick this bishop around one more
time instead of that though
bobby fischer leaves this pawn on h4 and
goes bishop d3
i'm immediately allowing black to trade
off these bishops
so who has a guess as to why
bobby chose to leave this pawn on h4
and to leave this knight on the f3
square
i'm asking you chatroom what do you
think the idea is
of leaving these two pieces where they
stand for the moment
rather than bring them further into the
action with h5 or
95.
see what you guys uh can come up with
here
as my chat actually fails to load
we'll try again uh
to stop g5 says uh chess king and that's
not quite the right idea it's not
necessarily that we are stopping this
move
by black but it is very much about the
g5 square
in the case of this h pawn uh bobby has
a very particular idea in mind and that
is to control g5
maybe even later uh you could envision a
g
pawn push by white if black were to
castle king's side
but this extra little bit of dark square
control
we're gonna see is is going to come in
very handy for white
as to the reason why bobby left this
knight on f3
your guess is as good as mine but i
think one good reason
is that after knight d7 black would be
immediately
offering some trades and it would make
white's play a little bit more forcing
as well as black's play
and instead we see bobby leaving these
pieces where they are
and perhaps giving himself a little bit
more freedom in the opening
we see e6 by black now just getting
ready to develop
bishop d2 is the main move by white
notably this bishop would be great on f4
but it runs into
actually some slight awkwardness on this
diagonal
it's not so comfortable for white to
leave this queen on a5 because white
very much would like to queen side
castle
and this queen would not allow it so
that's why you see the awkward square
of bishop d2 rather than the active
square on
f4 black now finishes development with
knight b to d7 we see queen side castles
and queen c7 so
we are 11 moves into the game and of
course i am claiming that this is a
miniature
and it's a little bit unclear how black
is destined
to lose this game in just a few more
moves so
what bobby does here is actually a
very very deeply conceived trap
uh what he starts with is just a
perfectly natural move in the carrow
bobby goes c4 the point of this move of
course is to just gain control
of the d5 square hint at a d5 break a
little bit later on
and try to suppress these black knights
keep them under wraps here without too
many squares
we see black queen side castle and then
already on
this exact move move 13
uh seemingly that there's not too much
going on just yet
but bobby lays a very very sneaky trap
that's uh robert steinmeier falls for
sort of hook line and sinker here so
what does bobby do
well he plays a perfectly good
developing
improving move and and that's what the
best traps do
at this top level you know they they
play seemingly in innocent improving
move but then the tactics that justify
that move
are sort of lurking behind the scenes
now
in today's matches most of the time
those tactics never surface because both
players sort of understand what's going
on
but in this particular game it ended so
quickly because steinmeier perhaps
underestimated bobby fischer's idea here
so what does bobby do
plays the simple move bishop c3 now
why does white want to play bishop c3
well it's you know pretty obvious this
is going to be a good diagonal white
wants to open it up
and it defends his pawn supports a
knight coming to e5 later on
just a good developing improvement move
now if black plays accurately here
probably the best thing to do is just
simply develop this bishop
and then the game is just going to
continue uh it's nothing too crazy
probably 94
by white stepping out of this and like i
said
the game is going to continue on from
here probably c5 by black
d5 by white coming in the near future
and it'll be a chess game right
no huge mistakes by either side
but steinmeier in the game perhaps
suspected that bishop e3
might be a little bit um too loose
to get away with what does every move in
chess do well
it comes with drawbacks right this is
something maurice ashley loves to say
aikido chess every move has a drawback
what's the drawback to bishop c3
well you used to be defending all these
lovely squares
along this diagonal and you no longer
have that sort of defensive coverage
so black goes queen f4 check and at
first glance this
is not really doing anything too crazy
it just checks the king
bobby just plays king b1 you know very
innocently just moving the king out of
check
and then black plays the move knight to
c5 and all of a sudden things start to
look a little bit
tough for white at least optically this
knight is
coming into the game going to be
attacking some weaknesses
over here on the king's side of the
board and
white may find himself in a lot of
trouble
bobby again just retreats the queen of
course you cannot capture this knight
due to the pin on the d
file so queen c2 and black's idea was to
bring this knight out to e4 and you know
at first glance everything is
is going according to plan what's what's
the big deal here black has
occupied the center with the knights f2
is
horrendously weak knight takes g3 is
also going to be a big threat in the
position
uh and black seems to be doing great uh
if not
for this idea by bobby fischer so chat i
want to turn it to you again
what was bobby fischer's idea what was
his conception here
that allows him to win this game in
glorious fashion
in glorious fashion
and yeah chess king is hitting on the
right idea here and that is
that this queen is running a bit low
on squares and perhaps the reason
uh this pawn was left on h4 is bobby
knew he wanted to reroute this bishop to
this diagonal
in some cases a little bit later on and
now this pawn is doing some of the work
that this bishop used to do
on the c1h6 diagonal in fact
it's helping to hamper this queen a
little bit so what could be the
idea and yeah the chat is coming up with
a pretty good candidate
move which is knight e5 but is knight e5
working
is it correct what does black have
after knight e5 this is an equally
important question
to to ask first of all what is our idea
with knight e5 we're attacking this but
is that enough
and then secondly what does black have
in response
chess king says knight takes g3 then
queen f5 i'm not
so sure that is actually getting the job
done right
knight takes f7 would be coming at the
end of that line and
your rooks would be fought let's go
ahead and put knight e5
on the board just just to help out here
we're threatening to trap the queen how
are we threatening to trap the queen
that's a bold claim there fx that we're
threatening to trap the queen
show me the way
anish says d5 and opening the c file i
assume it might mean
c5 but it's a bit slow right this is a
pretty big thread here this is a pretty
big threat
does 92 trap the queen to my eyes it
looks like
queen f5 is is available to the queen
d5 then rook d4 you guys are playing a
lot of moves at once
right whenever you move this is a big
secret in chess then your opponent gets
to move
it's a disaster honestly
bishop d2 is this the idea i think
knight takes d2 remains legal
yes so unfortunately this trap was so
deeply conceived by bobby fischer
way back when he played bishop c3 i'm
fairly certain
he saw this coming when he played bishop
c3 and the chat
and honestly myself if you ask me this
question would have a hard time
coming up with the exact idea right away
so the the main point for white it is in
fact just this
f7 pawn it it's an incredibly difficult
pawn to to try to defend here
right if you go knight d6 at the very
least we have this move c5
the knight moves again and we're going
to be able to take this and win the game
quite convincingly right
you can't give up f7 and these two rooks
which
by the way this is why i really don't
like these queen sight castles
variations
in the cairo con quite often f7 just
ends up being a horrible horrible
weakness so our threat is knight f7
it's a difficult threat to stop but the
reason why this trap is so cool
is that uh seemingly black has
active counter play right you know who
cares about f7
because black is able to take on f2
right this is this is the key move
that black has available and now queen
takes g3 seems pretty impossible to stop
right if you take on f7 uh what's going
on
if you take on f7
well i think yeah simply something like
knight takes d1 or knight takes h1 or
queen takes g3 any of those moves after
knight f7
and it looks like black is still very
much in the game
so what was the idea about knight f2
how does white win in this
position
rick hf1 well that's not really the end
of the story right
rick hf1 this piece is
currently hanging i could take it if i
so desired
should take free pieces when you can
there's also moves like night g4 to
consider there's a lot going on here
there's a lot going on here
so chat room what's the win
what is the win
so chess king is giving me a technically
winning variation
but where is you know your your sense of
uh whatever you call it your sense of of
art
uh so of course the better move uh
besides rick hf1 uh
the line that chess can give by the way
is is very good for white i believe
queen g3 queen f2 is what he was giving
here here knight e4 is playable though
that you have to look out for
and yes white is winning if you do this
or if you do this
it's just very good for white but it's
not nearly winning enough
do better do better than this line
diver says rook f1 yes but witch rook
and why
92 queen f5 g4 i could trade the queens
come on my friends come on i could take
this as well
all right i believe in the chat room i
believe that you guys can get this one
so chess king says or rook d to f1 okay
so if you guys haven't
found the solution just yet i would
encourage you to guys you guys to pause
at home i don't want to spend all
lecture on this position
but the idea is in fact rook d to f1
with the really really cool point that
after
queen takes g3 we don't take this piece
with the queen when we get this knight
e4 line which is pretty good for white
uh maybe even winning but not you know
stunning not a stunning miniature
instead we get
rook takes f2 and now what's the point
well you start looking around the board
you look at all these squares
you work on h1 by the way not the work
on d1
covers this pawn you look at these
squares
you look at this square you look at that
square you look at this square and this
square
and you start to say huh looks like that
queen is still trapped
even without the knight on g3 we
are trapping this queen and it's simply
impossible to stop you can go queenie
queen e3 but now
rookie one uh queen g3
rook f3 that queen is in the trap
nowhere to go
even from e3 all the squares are covered
all the squares are covered and that
would be
the match um so that's the idea
rook f2 and this queen is actually
incredibly
incredibly it is trapped no way out
for this queen uh what about this move
knight g4
well this is a bit a bit more boring
white can just capture this knight on g4
there's a pin on the f file
and then take this with the queen and be
up a free piece again
totally totally winning for white with
the extra piece
so rook d to f1 was the insane trap
but this only gets more impressive the
deeper back you go you can say okay
you know clearly black is a [ __ ] who
would ever play knight c to e4 here you
know obviously
bobby had this 95 move in mind why not
just retreat and then call it a day
well the fact is with this move knight
c5
black had already fallen for the trap
there's no turning back at this point
after queen c2
this knight is attacked you must do
something with it and if you think
you're going to retreat
knight e5 again comes in full force and
this knight takes f7 idea
is almost impossible to stop the only
way is with knight take c5
and then after this idea let's say
knight g4
it turns out black is going to have all
the same problems
takes takes rook d1 check king c8
rook d4 and again this queen finds
itself completely stuck queen f2 the
only move and again
white is just winning a piece absolutely
for free
so this deep conception by bobby with
bishop c3
uh he knew all along that knight c5 was
a losing move
and black just fell right into his plan
so what seemingly uh at first glance you
know i did sort of explain along the way
but when you first look at this game at
least when i first look at this game i
was like why is
why is this game so impressive black
just got his queen stuck on
on the king's side that you know nothing
nothing really doing here like why would
this be a memorable
memorable game by bobby fisher but then
the deeper you look
you start to realize that it's it's all
in this bishop c3 move right
bobby knew knight c5 was going to be
losing and
black just didn't understand why so
questions on on this game questions on
what's going on here
fx says it was probably preparation um i
i don't know it's it's 1963 they don't
really have these
these super computers doing all their
prep for them and we're reasonably deep
into the game like this isn't a common
uh position by any stretch of the
imagination
in the database i'm using since like
1970 this has
occurred something like eight times
definitely not not super mainline theory
here i think so maybe bobby prepped it
but
it is still impressive
nonetheless so
queen f4 check knight c5 and black is
busted
by the way if you play knight c5 without
queen f4 then it just really doesn't
make any sense
because this knight can't even come here
and you would just have to retreat
that's why queen f4 happened before this
94 idea
alright let's move on to our next giant
of the game
winning in miniature fashion and we of
course are going to talk about
the one the only magnus carlsen
and he uh was up against anish giri
actually in a grand chess tour event so
we like those
and uh this was back in zagreb
croatia i believe i don't remember the
year but we'll figure it out
and the niche gary had white now my
timeline on all the the twitter banter
is
a bit fuzzy so i don't know if this was
in the midst
of you know anish geary magnus carlson's
big trash talk back and forth that they
do all the time
but i'm sure looking back magnus has
some fond memories
of this game so anish had white here and
the game starts
again with one e4 and magnus
started with the sicilian uh we get
knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 this rossolimo stuff is what
all the
all it's all the rage with those top
players
magnus goes e6 going for control of the
d5 square
and anish just captures on c6 unprovoked
now after b takes c6 sort of the
character of the game that we're going
to look at
is bla white is aiming to play against
this bishop a little bit
uh playing for some extra central space
whereas black is going to have a nice
central presence as well with these two
c pawns providing some support
of these squares anish plays the move d3
again looking to shut down some of these
diagonals a little bit
magnus continues with knight e7 just
getting developed
knight f6 can sometimes run into an e5
move
and uh well that would be okay e7 is
just a good square for the knight as
well you also don't want to get pinned
in some cases
so 97 looking for these sorts of squares
we get h4 by a niche gear and while this
isn't like a novelty
this very much is a sideline it's not
the most common move
and it is going to be a little bit
suspect
so on its surface h4 seems like a good
move
you're just sort of preemptively
launching your king's side attack
notably this knight on the e7 isn't
really coming to f5 or d5
so it's looking like it's going to come
to g6 and so
h4 sort of plays directly against this
idea with the idea of h5
to sort of boot this knight out of the
way at any moment
so magnus responds in kind with h5
making that
idea highly illegal for a niche and
preparing to bring this knight here
anyways
so why did anish go for this well it's
going to be
a little bit of a battle between whose h
pawn is actually weaker here
magnus is going to be looking to prove
that the h4 pawn
is the biggest weakness whereas aneesh
is going to be
applying some pressure to this h5 pawn
himself and
in addition to that white makes one
other huge gain
with this trade-off and that is the g5
square black is no longer able
to play a move like h6 to evict a white
piece from g5
and that's a pretty massive gain for
white
with this dark squared thinking in mind
anish continues with the move e5
looking to take over some of these
squares but magnus is having none of it
and plays d6 to get these squares back
rather quickly
e takes d6 is played and now we do still
see
knight g6 by the world champion
this was always the square for the night
and it now makes even more sense with
this
little bit of pressure on the h4 pawn
it's a race to get developed now anish
plays
the slightly strange looking knight f to
d2
what's the point well the point is this
knight is going to be better served
coming to one of these squares
attacking d6 and controlling the center
than it was on f3
and again it's a question of h4
versus h5 now uh
gary is offering up this h pawn to
magnus with the caveat that after it
gets captured
look out for a move that
kicks this knight out of the way when
after knight f5 white is going to be
recapturing here
on the h5 pawn and probably is going to
have the more active pieces
if this queen gets brought into play so
ned fd2 a strange looking move and
perhaps not the greatest move in the
position
i think better for a niche would have
been a normal developing move
activating these queen side pieces but
knight fd2 is an interesting idea as
well
magnus continues normally with bishop
takes d6 we get knight to c4
and now magnus has to make a decision uh
this diagonal or this diagonal so bishop
e7 or bishop c7
chat room what do you think which
diagonal makes more sense
for the bishop here
and i'm being told that youtube is down
for a large portion of the planet
which is awkward because we're streaming
to youtube
so here i think definitely the square to
go to for magnus
is going to be the e7 square why
is that well once again it's going to be
about magnus trying to apply a little
bit of
pressure to this h4 pawn now if you go
to a square like c7
i'm not saying this is the worst move of
all time but you're not
really going to be putting much pressure
on anything on this diagonal
you want to look to pressure the h4 pawn
so i like e7 a bit better
and that's where magnus chooses to go uh
it's all about early on in openings like
these
i think both players were sort of out of
book reasonably early
and it's just about making sure your
pieces make sense with each other
if you go bishop c7 then this knight and
this bishop are sort of playing two
different games
as well as this queen the queen and
knight are focusing on h4
this bishop is focusing on this other
diagonal and together it doesn't make
that much sense
so bishop e7 keeps all the pieces
working together and that's why i like
this move
geary continues very naturally with the
move knight c3
looking for some e4 square squares
perhaps
and now magnus has to figure out what to
do with this bishop
thankfully it's not the hardest decision
of all time
one option is to actually go e5 with the
idea of bringing the bishop out this way
but i like what magnus did in the game
which is bishop a6
and just trading off this bishop for
this knight on c4
we see queen f3 by anish
geary and now it's decision time for
magnus
you had an idea your idea was to take on
c4
are you going to flinch at the puny
little queen take c6 threat
or uh are you gonna do bishop take c4
anyways
or are you going to defend your c6 pawn
with something like rook c8 something
like
queen to c7 perhaps and
chat what do you think here what should
be done
and maybe i just have to stop asking the
chatroom questions because youtube is
broken
all right well in this case uh
magnus actually chooses correctly in
this case if you do something like
defend your c7 pawn
very simply the fact of the matter is
white is going to be a little bit better
after
one really important consolidating move
what move is that
what's the move g3 if white gets to play
g3
then even after you get this bishop off
the board your pawn structure is going
to be a little bit worse
you just have a few too many weaknesses
to keep track of
this knight for the moment isn't looking
the happiest
in the world and once white finishes
development with something simple like
bishop e3 even something like bishop d2
to facilitate queenside castles i think
white is just gonna be a little bit
better
so magnus senses the urgency in the
position and
that is why he ends up with a good
position here uh
always be on the lookout to tell if your
position is in danger of becoming worse
it's good to stop and evaluate who has
the long-term advantages and who has the
short-term advantages
in this case it's black with the extra
pressure on the h4 pawn
and a short-term advantage if in the
long term
white is able to consolidate with the
move g3
and then it's actually going to be white
with a little bit of an edge
notably even in this position i think
geary's best move
would have been g3 why didn't he play g3
well he was probably worried that the
position would be simplified a bit too
much
if black trades the queens and perhaps
this is true
as well that being said i think this
would have been pretty good
for white with you know at least a small
advantage to continue pushing after
knight takes d1
but instead queen f3 the more active try
and
magnus you know accepts the challenge
takes on c4
geary now takes on c6 and we get king f8
and d takes c4 so what was magnus's idea
well now that this queen has left the
attack of this h pawn
we can in fact capture on h4 earlier
this would have been
a big mistake if we try to do this here
well okay first of all this is hanging a
piece so if we tried to do this
here then once again g3 would have been
the response
and thanks to this queen's pressure
white is going to be better after rook
takes h5
however in the game by drawing this
queen to c6
magnus realized that this was actually a
pretty bad square for the queen in more
ways than one
number one of course it's not defending
h5 but number two
this is actually just a vulnerable
square the the queen is a little bit
liable
to getting attacked here so we get d
take c4
and knight takes h4 now
geary plays what is probably the the
beginning of the end
this next move is what gives the
advantage over to magnus
and then magnus quickly compounds that
advantage and wins the game in short
order
and that move is king side castles and i
just think this is a pretty bad move
gary's idea was probably to rapidly take
control over this
d file and use it to pressure the black
king
but of course it comes at the risk of
putting your own king
sort of in the line of fire you've given
up this h pawn
black already has this pawn on h5 and
it's going to be a dangerous home
for the black for the white king over
here magnus continues with knight f5
and now we see again the vulnerability
of this queen on c6
knight d4 is coming with tempo and
attacking many things at the same time
there's f5 ideas after queen e4
it's going to be a little bit awkward
for white to keep everything together
because of that geary chose knight to e2
and now magnus is very very firmly in
control here 92 stops knight d4
but now we see this queen get attacked
once again with rook c8
and by the way i still think queen e4
would have been
the better option but giri sort of go
goes
full uh greedy pawn grubber here and
plays queen
a4 going going after the a7 pawn
so geary has made a couple mistakes in
this game
number one he puts his king in the line
of fire
and then number two he puts his queen on
the opposite side of the board
where it is cut off from returning to
the action
and whenever that happens you should
have one thing on your mind and of
course that thing
is checkmate so how do you actually play
for checkmate here
well there are some ideas that should be
pretty natural to you
which involves you know pushing these
pawns up the board
but then how do you get the heavy hitter
into the game
how do you get this queen over to the
king site
that is the brilliant idea that allowed
magnus
to to win this game so quickly
so chat room um i guess i'm still gonna
ask you
maybe i won't ask the chat room i don't
think there's too many people left
with the youtube difficulties but um
how do you get this queen into the
action uh go ahead pause the video at
home if you want to try to figure it out
for yourself
the idea is actually to do it along
not the dark squares because white is
able to guard these with bishop f4
but actually along the light squares
with an idea
such as queen a8 how do you make that
happen well magnus uses dual purpose
moves getting the queen into the action
and at the same time slowing down
white's play on the d
file and that dual purpose move is rook
c7
what's the point the point is after
bishop f4 rook
d7 and magnus is stopping rook d1
defending this a pawn as well and has
cleared the way
for the queen to enter the action now c3
by
whites and black to move and have a
winning advantage
c3 of course is an attempt to get rook
d1 back on the table but it
is too slow at this point
so of course the way to continue is with
g5 gaining time on this bishop
and now geary's position is is sort of
approaching
hopeless here he put this bishop in the
line of fire and it's only going to
accelerate black's attack from here on
out we see rook ad1 by geary this
is now a threat so rick takes d1 rook
takes d1 and then the brilliant
queen a8 black is now attacking
the white king from about as far away as
you can be
on the a8 square and white is sort of
helpless to put anything
in the way bishop c7 was geary's choice
but now simply h4
and now it looks like gary sort of is
giving up the game without a fight
but the fact of the matter is it's very
very difficult to play a move here with
white
and in fact you know i i would go as far
as to say
impossible so what is uh
what is magnus threatening here well
magnus is threatening let's say you do
nothing
threatening to play h3 why is this move
such a big deal
well this is a checkmate threat and if
you take here
then the simple rook takes h3 and queen
h1
is is going to be unstoppable you just
can't stop this queen
from coming into the action here if king
f1 then
rook h1 for example and queen e4
again difficult to suggest moves here
for white as everything
is going to be winning so to my eyes at
least
i wondered why doesn't geary try the
defensive looking
rook to d3 and the answer is
magnus is still checkmating by force
here it is just
such dominance on the light squares
around white's king
that's uh there's simply no defense
magnus would still be able to push
h3 and after the seemingly defending
rook takes h3 getting the major piece
off the board
rook h3 pawn h3 now black to move and
win
of course knight h4 is just an
unstoppable attack here
just devastating attack queen g2 check
is impossible to stop if you go king f1
trying to run
you can run for a little bit but your
run is quickly cut short
by some nastiness over here some
nastiness some very nasty nastiness
all right i'm not gonna play any more
moves i hope you get the point
by now uh so what did gary try
well he tried to move f3 but still this
move h3
comes through and gary had had enough
after h3 and resigned the game
on move 23 a pretty devastating victory
for geary and a very impressive win by
magnus carlson
recognizing the urgency in the position
allowing queen takes c6 with check
and then pushing for the victory while
limiting
counter play what more could you ask for
in a 23 move chess game
um all right well those of you still
with us
any questions on this game before we
move
on
all right then let us move on
the next player i want to cover which by
the way
these i think are the top three chess
players in all of history
as i mentioned at the top of the hour
we've seen a game by bobby fisher
we've seen a game by magnus carlson
who's left
well you probably guessed it the one the
only
gary kasparov has plenty of miniatures
to his name
of course he probably has the the most
wild attacking reputation of any of
those three players
and in this case we're going to take
another look at a game
with the black pieces gary had black
against alexander mirozovich
and let's see what happened here we once
again are going to look at another e4
game
but this time we get the rather more
timid
e5 gary meeting e4 with e5 no crazy
sicilian wins
no crazy caro con traps just good
old-fashioned e4
e5 that is until you see mirozovich's
next move
which is f4 and so now of course we are
in
for a fairly wild and crazy game
uh gary captures on f4 with the e pawn
and we get knight f3
which is the main move and then rather
than the main line
with g5 and gary kasparov chose the line
with d6 which is also
quite common uh borderline the main line
i think
and here uh mirozovic decides to take
over the center with d4
very natural stuff we get g5 by
gary h4 by mirozovich g4 by gary
and here the theory goes
knight back to g1 and something like
bishop out to h6
queen out to f6 both of these moves
aimed at defending the f
pawn or something more active like f5 or
knight f6
going after the e pawn however in this
case mirozovich
plays the move knight g5 not with the
idea of
retreating but with the idea of taking
this f-pawn off the board in true king's
gambit style
so gary is not one to shy away from a
challenge here
and chose the move h6 now if you ever
you know have the misfortune to find
yourself facing this uh yourself
i would recommend this move f6 instead i
think it's a bit
simpler for black to deal with than the
lines after h6 this is still going to be
a peace sacrifice
as this knight is totally trapped but
it's a
sacrifice that's a bit easier to hold on
to after bishop f4
fg5 and then either bishop or pawn takes
and your king does not get drawn out to
the f7 square
instead gary chose h6 when after knight
takes f7
king takes f7 and bishop takes f4
gary now has one piece developed and
that piece
is his king so
the question is how do you go about
trying to consolidate
a position like this there are plenty of
openings
in chess that that wind up with some
crazy sacrifice like this
most of them are very very good for
black some of them are winning for white
because black is messed up somewhere
along the way
but if you ever do find yourself in a
position like this against an opponent
willing to play some dubious sacrifices
against you how do you actually go about
consolidating how do you go about
developing your pieces finding safety
for your king
and the best answer to that question i
think is to
just start calculating which sounds kind
of obvious
but more than that you want to look
specifically
at your opponent's threats and at your
opponent's
best place pieces so here
gary plays the move bishop g7 which i
think is a good move
but i think may not be the most accurate
move in the position
for defending so looking at this
position
the number one move that would strike my
eyes with the white pieces
is bishop c4 check so of course i'm
going to think along the lines
how do i actually stop bishop c4 and i
think i would want to play the move
bishop e6 well i can still get a lot of
compensation for the piece
by just developing normally with bishop
d3 but then transposing to what gary
played with bishop g7
i do think this is going to be a little
bit of a better version
for black than what we saw in the game
if d5
kicking this bishop i'm happy to retreat
safe in the knowledge
that bishop c4 check is is not going to
happen to me anytime
soon just for example the game might
continue
king's side castles knight f6 blocking
any discovered checks
e5 trying to open things up takes takes
rookie 8
and now it's sort of anyone's guess as
to what is is going on here
although of course black is keeping the
the extra piece
so i think maybe bishop v6 would have
been good and
i didn't do too much of a deep dive into
it but optically
i think this is a better practical move
for black just because it sort of
hinders
what white was looking to do with this
bishop c4 check idea
instead though we get bishop g7 and
white does in fact play this move bishop
c4 check
now gary has to make a decision do you
come up the board
or down the board and this is also
a fairly difficult decision to make with
the black pieces
of course your first instinct is
probably to retreat the king
like a sane person but you know king g6
is not without merit as well the point
being you just get off this back rank
and have a little bit more space around
your king you're looking to sort of
retreat back into an h7 hidey hole
but in this case i do believe king e8 is
the right choice
why is that well after king g6 is a very
impressive move for white here
and that move of course is e5 just
ripping things open
this diagonal opens up and this king is
going to find itself
in some hot water so king e8 is
kasparov's choice and i
agree with this one then mirozovich
kingside castles and i think this is
what throws away the advantage
and gives black the the upper hand sort
of similar
to what we saw in the magnus carlson
game
uh so what's going on after king's side
castles
well gary decides he's in fact not so
interested
in uh you know staying on the back foot
for the remainder of the game
and starts counter-attacking so why is
kingside castles a bad
move well i think first and foremost
the main issue here is that it demands a
response to any attack to the d4 upon
with the king on e1 maybe white can
actually sacrifice this pawn
in some instances but with the king on
g1 it's going to be very difficult
because bishop takes d4 is going to come
with a check to the white king
and gary continues just like that with
knight c6
now white already starts moving
backwards with bishop e3
and after queen takes h4 seemingly out
of nowhere
it is black who is attacking white and
has an extra piece
as well so what would have been better
uh
well i think better than castles is the
developing move knight c3
and i did a little bit of analysis in
this position and i found it to be quite
interesting i think white
may actually be close to winning in this
position which is sort of
not what i would expect at at first
glance you know obviously white has some
compensation for the piece
but i wouldn't expect white to actually
be close to winning
uh and what's the point of knight c3
well the point is basically just that it
gets the knight in the game and it's not
putting the king
on g1 if black continues as in the game
and as
i think he should with knight c6 going
after the d4 pawn
now white is willing to sacrifice this
pawn with queen d3
and the tempting bishop takes d4
is a move away from completely
consolidating
sadly uh though it will remain a move
away
if white plays something slow like queen
side castles then black is going to be
doing great
after bishop e5 black gets this nice
little blockader can continue with
something like knight e7
and will likely be in the game however
white has the stunning move e5 here and
this
is what rips open everything by force
and is going to lead to an advantage for
white for example if you continue with
knight ge7
now e takes d6 c takes d6 queenside
castles
and with the open e file it's very much
a different story
compared to to what we just looked at
although
you know the result is still very much
going to be up in the air
it's it's still anyone's game but this
looks optically
very dangerous for black so
i think knight c3 is a much better move
than
king side castles even a move like queen
d3 i think is better
anything that doesn't put this king on
g1 because
the king on g1 makes white lose time and
time is the one thing white cannot
afford to lose in this position
but kingside castles in the game knight
c6
now it's too late to go for things like
this because again bishop takes d4 check
is going to just be very very strong
in fact it's close to checkmating if you
move the king
look out you are in trouble
so white has to defend this pawn and now
queen takes h4
and gary is just uh cruising here
that being said rook f7 by
white and gary comes up with a nice
defensive move
rook h7 and you know the bishops
attacked might as well defend it right
rook h8 to h7
not the most common defensive move but a
good one in this case
white was not ready to throw in the
towel though and continue with the move
e5 this is the attacking idea that we've
seen before
and it makes sense here as well and
now it is black to move and
win the game so i want to turn it to you
guys at home
those of you who are with me and those
of you watching the replay go ahead
and pause the video here to try and
figure out what black should do
to win the game there are many moves in
the position but i
i do like what gary did in the game sort
of the best here
so black to move
[Music]
so pip and chuck says g3 and g3 is
definitely going to be a key
idea but it is not going to win the game
in this case if you play g3
you are actually very much in danger of
losing the game
that's right white has a winning idea in
this position
and it goes in junction with this move
e5
so what can white do here white can play
queen d3
and then all of a sudden you are running
out of ways to defend this rook on h7
and if this rook moves you're running
out of ways to defend this bishop
on g7 queen h2 is a check but nothing
more
if you check me again i can block
queen h5 for example and okay well that
would be a mistake
but knight c3 defending this way and
your problems aren't going away
on h7 so g3 not a good move
not a good move
sacking the rook for the attack what
attack
there's no attack unless
um okay there's just no attack with only
these two pieces
if white has all these defenders around
the king right king f1 bishop g1
and your attack ends
so what can you do
yeah pip and chuck is not interested in
winning objectively it's all about the
psychological war and bishop takes e5
his psychological dominance according to
pip and chuck
and fair enough it is a very appealing
move and it is in fact
going to be slightly better for black
after some moves here queen h2 check
king f1 is bad because this is coming
after queen h1 but king f2 keeps the
game going
check here takes and it's true black is
doing pretty well
in this position but black has much
better
so after e5 what does gary kasparov play
well he just attacks this bishop on c4
he says yeah if you go after my rook
i am coming after your rook and that's
that so now queen d3
of course is going to be that my knight
takes c4 and this
is going to be met my king takes f7 for
the second time in the game
gary is going to draw the king back out
to f7 to capture a piece
in the game we saw bishop d3 by
mirozovich but this still runs into king
takes f7
and now after check king e7 this time
takes on h7
and the simple developing move bishop e6
is
going to be close to the end of the game
here black is now
almost fully developed with this rook
coming to f8
uh the king has found some safety and
black is just up
a full piece here knight d2 played rook
f8
takes on on d6 with check takes queen e2
and then the simple king d8 stepping off
the file
there's really nothing left to play for
for white
c3 was mirozovich's choice but now 97
and black is literally fully developed
rookie won in the game
bishop out to c4 is the nice finishing
tactic
with this queen now essentially trapped
on e2
you cannot take twice because this uh
this piece will be falling
in fact even if you take once then i
think still
g3 is going to be crushing here so
bishop f5 bishop f2 in the game then
rook takes f2
is the nice sacrifice and queen f2 g3
white resigns uh now
gary is of course defending the escape
route for the king
and queen h2 with mate is coming
so very impressive game by gary kasparov
here
and even more impressive when you
realize that it was in fact a
rapid game so gary fearless
gary kasparov takes on f7 with the king
and manages to defend in a rapid game no
easy task
by the way i want to mention that up
until the very end here
at the very ends of course we see this
you know nice little sacrifice where it
takes f2
up until that point gary captured all of
his opponents pieces
with his king all right that's not
something many people can say
he's taken a knight and a rook with his
king on the f7 square and live to tell
the tale
all he does capture pieces with his king
pretty
impressive stuff um
okay so any questions on this game
and then since we do have a little bit
of time i am going to show you
a fourth game from a fourth player
nearly as good
as these first three that we looked at
nearly as good just goes to show the
king is immortal
not quite not quite especially if you're
playing with the white pieces here
all right well let's move on to one more
miniature and this time it's not bobby
fisher it's not magnus carlson
it's not gary kasparov it's yours truly
it's caleb
denby with a miniature uh i
had a wonderful game actually earlier
this year probably
the last wonderful game i uh and playing
over the board
for some time uh uh against
a st louis player by the name of alex
zhang and so i wanted to highlight this
one as well
again somehow it's going to be our third
miniature with
the black pieces uh that i had against
alex
and we've only got a few minutes left so
let's take a look at it
alex started with d4 i go knight f6
c4 e6 knight f3
d5 knight c3 so
white has avoided the nimzo indian by
playing this move knight f3 first and
then after d5
knight c3 i play the move bishop b4
no longer a nimso indian because this
move in this mover inserted but
in fact just a ragozan defense
and there are many lines in the ragozan
some
are sort of simpler than others but alex
chose the tempting option of queen a4
check
why is this option so tempting well it
of course forks king and bishop
and forces the move knight c6 to stop
both threats why is this so desirable
for white well often times in queen's
pawn openings
it is very very good to develop the
knight behind the pawn
for example white develops this knight
behind the c pawn and due to that
is able to apply a lot of pressure to
both of these squares these two pieces
just work well together
and from the black side it can be
favorable to place something like c6 to
defend the d5 pawn
or actually move like c5 to pressure
white's center as well
and so by forcing knight c6 white is
sort of
making black's pieces look less than
ideal in some cases
bishop g5 is how my opponent continued
and i play the move h6
asking my opponent to make a decision
with this bishop
and now combined with queen a4 bishop g5
after h6 this should really be met with
the move
bishop takes f6 why
is that well you've actually wasted a
little bit of time
to play this move queen a4 you brought
your queen out to the side of the board
uh removing it from the center of the
board where it is actually
being useful to guard the center guard
the d4 square
so this move is sort of developing my
knight for free right
that's the downside to queen a4 so after
bishop g5
you you know sort of better believe that
you can't be wasting any more time
with your pieces in my opponent played
bishop f4
which is in this case just going to be a
little bit too slow it gives black a
little bit
too much time in the opening much better
as bishop takes f6 this is just a main
main line
queen takes f6 and then e3 when white is
going to finish development comfortably
but bishop f4 instead is my opponent's
choice
i insert the move bishop d7 which by the
way if you've ever played the ragosan
before
you probably know this one little tactic
that often appears
and it's the tactic of bishop d7 right
it's tempting for white to just play a
move
like e3 claiming that with any discovery
your bishop is going to be hanging
but black to move and win here is of
course
the move knight takes d4 when
you're in for a rude awakening with
knight c2 check
forking king and queen now it wouldn't
be
too impressive if i won in this manner
and my opponent did see this move and
played the move queen c2
just retreating the queen so now we see
one
two three wasted moves by white
and that is just a few too many that's
just a few too many
so chat room and those of you
at home uh black to move here how should
black continue in this position
you get the feeling that your opponent
is just wasting so much time
there has to be something good for you
but what is it
what should you do here what to play
arthur asks is this the manhattan
variation and i actually don't know
the specific name of it i just know it
as the queen a4 line
and pip and chuck actually does have the
right idea here you want to soften up
white's control of d4 and the way to do
that is to make use of this
h6 pawn and go g5 this is it
now you're not immediately actually
winning d4 you would be if this bishop
comes back to g3
when now all of a sudden this knight has
nowhere to go
and knight takes d4 is going to be
coming
but instead bishop e5 does hold on to
things for a little bit
that being said g4 is still going to be
the idea
knight back to d2 and now
once again black to move and press for
the advantage how do you keep things
flowing
you shook up the white pieces before
they finish developing
developing but now how do you continue
how to continue here what to do
so as we are a bit long time and
actually no i don't just have to reveal
the answer because arthur in the chat
does have it
you need to open things up when you're
ahead in development when you're
pressing you want to
open the center open things up and the
way to do that here
is with the move knight takes e5 pawn
takes e5
and then you continue pressing with the
move d4
and this is what gives black the
advantage in this case
if you take on f6 don't even think about
it i am taking here
and after pawn takes i'm not retreating
i'm taking on f6
and you are pinned up into the next
century
basically there's no way out of this
this stuff here queen e4
queen e5 is available if knight e4 and
no time to develop this piece
f5 is coming and this is just disaster
disaster disaster disaster
so my opponent kept the game going
played the move knight d1
and then i just continue with knight h5
looking to attack some of these squares
as well
my opponent continues with e3 a very
natural move trying to keep the knight
out of f4
and develop this piece but now after
bishop c6
it's going to be difficult for white to
actually achieve these developing goals
the bishops are active this night well
for the moment sidelined
is always in dangerous position to
invade and this is just a very tough
position here
for white they tried to move a3 which is
a good try
and just retreated back to bishop e7 now
b4 by white is an act of try to
get rid of this bishop but unfortunately
it's just not
quite enough i went bishop h4 in the
game
applying some pressure here and after b5
d takes e3 opening things up hitting
this knight
knight takes e3 and now black to move
what can be done here
what to do in fact there is only
one move for black but it is going to be
a good one here
it's the move queen to d4 this is the
active idea that i think
alex missed in the game what's the point
well if you save the rook then queen
takes e3
and queen takes f2 and when i played
this move
i was feeling quite proud of myself i
was quite pleased
with what i had done i was like queen d4
white can resign but white could have
actually
saved the game here alex had the
opportunity
to only be a little bit worse and he
would have ruined my miniature
with the surprisingly legal queen side
castles
so it pays to know the the all of the
rules to castling
you save the rook it doesn't matter that
the queen attacks this square
castling is still legal with the king
and here
bishop takes f2 is the best i can do and
the the game
will continue here uh it is going to be
good for for black
but the game would at least keep going
but in the game b takes c6 was alex's
choice
and then i just captured the rook on a1
knight b1 queen takes e5 takes on b7
takes on e3 king d1 rick d a check
knight d2
queen takes a3 and i think alex actually
did continue the game
for a little bit but for the purposes of
this lecture we're going to say the game
ended on move 22
so i can claim it was a miniature um
that's gonna do it for tonight's lecture
hopefully you enjoyed these four
miniature games from
four of the world's best chess players
or at least
three um i had a lot of fun going over
these games
if you're watching live stay tuned for
the end game class which i think we are
just gonna do
on youtube hopefully these technical
difficulties on youtube's end
do get resolved pretty soon but it's
it's going to be a fun one
today for end games all right
that's it thank you all so much for
watching this edition of the road to
2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you